if you own one of these pairs airpods 2
or the original and you don't want to
spend the money don't try these out
apple finally updated their earpods
compare them to the airpods 2 the
airpods pro apple actually lowered the
price the airpods 3 case is actually
smaller than the airpods pro compared to
the airpods 2 case it's basically the
same size just that different design bam
look at that guys another vent at the
top here instead of bottom with the air
pro the stem design is the same but it
is actually thicker on the airpods 3. of
course compared to the air pods too the
design is a lot different these airpods
3 definitely feel a little bit more snug
than the airpods 2. this is a microphone
quality with apple's air pods too this
is the microphone quality with apple's
new earpods 3. this is the microphone
quality with apple's airpods pro you get
support for dolby atmos these are louder
the brand new airpods 3 they actually
have better bass than the sealed airpods
pro